jacqueline gourault est l'invité
d'auditions publiques pour soir madame
la ministre soir et merci d'être avec
nous donc présentes à ce rendez vous des
chaînes parlementaires de la sp et du
figaro d'ailleurs les internautes qui
nous suivent sur le figaro live peuvent
réagir en direct via le chat et poser
leurs questions et je me ferais bien sûr
votre relais auprès de jacqueline
gourault vous êtes la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires en l'espèce des
fractures territoriales également
sociale
vous avez également en charge les
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales et là aussi c'est tendu à
d'ailleurs dans un instant vous
échangerez avec le sénateur et l'air
mathieu darnaud et le député socialiste
luc carvounas d'abord ici présents yves
thréard du figaro et polo brillant
messieurs bonsoir avant oriane mancini
et du devis cfo le bras de fer se
poursuit entre les jets les jaunes et et
le président de la république parce
qu'on entend ça va crescendo d'ailleurs
des appels à sa démission alors est ce
que vous voyez une issue à cette crise
il y a d'un côté des revendications
immédiates les gilet jaune et puis
apparemment de l'autre plutôt des
réponses à long et moyen terme un plan
mobilité ou encore une concertation
voyez vous estimez vous possible une
sortie de crise ce que je vois surtout
c'est que les gilets jaunes d'une
manière générale sont très divers en des
motivations différentes
j'en ai rencontré j'ai parlé avec eux
avec des gros j'ai pris le temps lors
d'une visite que j'ai fait dans le
département de la nièvre notamment et en
discutant avec eux on voit bien le
retraité agricole qu'à une toute petite
retraite
la jeune femme endettés
par sur l'endettement comme on dit
l'autre jeune femme qui élève seule
trois enfants et qu'ils n'y arrivent pas
même si elle travaille
on est très très loin qu'au rêve des
outrances verbales de monsieur darmanin
et de monsieur castaner ce castaner nous
parle de février 34
il parle de séditieux monsieur darmanin
nous parle de la peste brune qui a
envahi les champs elysées on al
impression là que dix on a perdu un peu
la raison non mais vous savez bien que
dans ce genre de situation les
manifestants évolué on sait très bien qu
entre le premier samedi où il y a eu des
comment dire des manifestations
spontanées de gens qui venaient des
campagnes de la ville et qui avait
ouvert la neige et puis le samedi
suivant où on a commencé à voir mais le
cigare à la main que parmi les gardés à
vue il n'ya pas un seul l'ultra-droite
pas un seul drague au genou c'est qu'il
sait ce sont des plombiers des agents
d'assurance des peut-être mais il y a eu
aussi on le sait des casseurs de l'huile
sur le feu au canon mais monsieur
thréard sur les champs-elysées c'était
pas des gentils manifestants
ben si c'est ce qu on a été gentil non
parce qu'ils sont satisfaisants tout
casser c'est quand même violent ça donne
une image de la france assez dramatique
tout ça ça passe sur les chaînes de
télévision dans le monde entier sédition
puisque je disais tout à l'heure il ya
des appels à la démission et d'ailleurs
on annonce peut-être une nouvelle
manifestation samedi 11 décembre
est ce que ça te regarde finalement que
le gouvernement n'a pas su bien gérer
puisqu'il ya un acte iii comme nous
disent ah ah ils appellent à manifester
à nouveau oui samedi
oui encore une fois c'est très difficile
parce que vous n'avez pas devant vous
des gens qui ont les mêmes
revendications et vous le savez très
bien
il ya des revendications diverses que
c'est très difficile d'apporter une
réponse
madame alors eh bien parce que ces
mécontentements d'abord ils viennent de
loin ça j'en suis absolument persuadé
tout à l'heure dans votre présentation
vous avez dit la fracture sociale et la
fracture territoriale
bon c'est une expression que l'on doit
comme vous le savez à jacques chirac
et il est vrai que l'évolution de la
société la mondialisation l'évolution de
la répartition de la population sur le
territoire
un monde qui va de plus en plus vite
tout cela il ya des gens qui se sentent
délaissés que ces tombes et les casseurs
renault alors puisque vous avez vous
êtes allé à leur rencontre dans la
nièvre
vous êtes en contact régulièrement avec
monsieur bayrou mais on a l'impression
que françois bayrou il vous donne le
conseil de parler avec ces gens là de
faire preuve d'humanisme
alors que les réponses du gouvernement
sont des réponses de techno d'ailleurs
j'ai l'impression françois bayrou il
aime pas beaucoup
edouard philippe un lidar man a dit le
maire après qu'est ce que vous
préconisez pour sa cohésion des
territoires
françois bayrou pourrait me dire de
faire cela mais il me le dit jamais
parce qu'il sait que je le fais
naturellement je n'attends personne pour
parler avec les gens c'est ma nature
depuis très longtemps et tout le monde
le sait donc j'ai mon attitude spontanée
effectivement quand j'ai vu des
manifestants qui attendaient devant la
mairie de cosne-sur-loire si vous voulez
savoir très précisément
je me suis dit il faut que j'aille leur
parler bon je les fais tout à fait
spontané le ciel de léon gouvernement
sait rester au gouvernement il y a une
comment dire une réponse à apporter au
malaise de ces gens qui m'agresse je
garde les bonnes réponses ont coûté le
président de la république va s'exprimer
demain matin et vous le savez très bien
il va faire des déclarations je pense je
ne connais pas le contenu bien
évidemment mais je pense que le
président de la république va montrer
notre souci de poursuivre comment dire
la transformation énergétique parce que
c'est important beaucoup d'autres l'ont
votée avant nous sans la faire l'idée
principal c'est de poursuivre cette
transition énergétique pour ne pas
comment dire serre que les générations
futures se trouvent dans des difficultés
majeures mais en même temps il faut et
il faut prendre des mesures qui soient
soutenables pour toute la population
quand vous repensez à certaines quand
elle est prise par exemple la hausse
annoncée encore en janvier
je n'ai pas parlé de renoncement c'est
inconscient il faut aujourd'hui
l'adaptation mais je n'ai pas il faut
poursuivre le cap moyens vidéo d'un
moratoire
oui répond que pour donner quotas
minutes ségolène royal quand elle était
au gouvernement elle pouvait prendre des
mesures elle ne les a pas prises il y a
une responsabilité qui est la nôtre la
transition écologique tous les français
s'en rendre compte quand même c'est on
sait bien que le réchauffement de la
planète c'est pas une histoire
deuxièmement il ya des problèmes de
santé public également
donc il faut répondre et il faut
effectivement se rendre compte que pour
une catégorie de la population
c'est difficile à supporter et parfois
même peut-être qu'on n'a pas fait assez
d'explications de pédagogie pour
expliquer cette année ce sont les
mesures vous nous a mis sur la même sur
la voie de mesures éventuellement
d'apaisement oui alors vous savez qu'un
certain nombre de mesures ont déjà été
prises et on regarde maintenant vers où
les matches les rappels n'aurait pas le
péage urbain pas la taxe poids lourds
tout ça mais est ce que je vous ai parlé
du chèque énergie des mesures de
transition cnt
les conversions il vient madame que vous
nous parler de l'avenir qui est celui
des enfants des petits enfants ou et que
les gens qui manifestent la de toute
bonne foi ils disent mais nous on a pas
on peut pas boucler nos fins qu'est-ce
que vous devrez dit à cela c'est pas un
haut conseil sur le climat mais les
vallées qui veut les apaiser je viens de
dire exactement ce que vous êtes en
train de me dire il faut concilier le
comment dire l'objectif est en même
temps que ce soit soutenable pour les
populations première ligne le président
de la république là maintenant ça y est
le président de la république est
toujours en première ligne mais la roma
demain si si si
10 n'est pas bien acceptés par régis des
jaunes ça va commencer à être compliqué
votre affaire mais je crois que le
président de la république va mobiliser
il a déjà dit l'ensemble de la société
parce que c'est quelque chose qui doit
se partager avec l'ensemble de la
société
il ya même des collectivités
territoriales puisqu'on va parler tout à
l'heure des collectivités territoriales
qui prennent des initiatives et il faut
peut-être regarder les accompagner pour
les bons exemples
il faut mettre tout le monde autour de
la table collectivités état partenaires
sociaux mais s'il demande à être moi je
suis des jeunes et ça s'est déjà fait
dans les départements par exemple dans
mon département
je sais que le préfet a reçu les jets
les autres on est dans un monde dont on
peut se parler au lieu d'allumer des
feux et de casser des voitures ou de
casser des vitrines sont les champs
elysées très concrètement vous parler
des gens qui ne peuvent pas assumer
assuré est ce qu'il faut je laissais
hausses de taxes sur les carburants ou à
tout le moins amoindri à la hausse
il faut que traîne ne soit plus soit
plus bas je sais j'ai ma beauté au jour
ce que je sais c'est ce que les
sénateurs ont voté aujourd'hui c'est ce
que françois bayrou a esquissé la
semaine dernière dans une interview au
figaro enfin est ce que vous dites votre
réponse esquissé l'idée de l'adapter en
fonction de la montée du prix du baril
brut c'est ça qu'il a essayé c'est plus
flottant et là je crois que le sénat a
voté carrément la suppression je n'ai
pas dans le gel de la hausse prévue en
janvier qu'en pensez vous est ce que
c'est une piste que selon vous que l'on
pourrait retenir
demain le président de la république va
parler c'est lui qui dira ce qu'il a à
dire
évidemment je les dis à l'instant il
faut ouvrir une phase de concertation et
ensuite prendre des décisions je dirais
peut-être aussi une nouvelle méthode
pour comment dire là où france ô une
nouvelle méthode pour peut-être mieux
entendre les français alors 6e réforme
et la méthode attendait c'est
intéressant ça c'est la première fois
qu'on nous parle d'une nouvelle méthode
bah écoutez je suis heureuse d'être la
première à le dire alors pourrait bien
passer ses invités précédent public à
cette nouvelle je ne navigue pas je suis
sûr qu'il va le faire c'est quoi ta job
méthode mais c'est à dire qu'on va
mettre tous les gens autour de la table
et qu'on va
discuter on va faire un grand grenelle
environnement la de grenade matignon
disons qu'on va se mettre sur les
territoires parce que je pense qu'il
faut aller sur les territoires discuter
à président de la république doit s'y
rendre lui-même président de la
république il choisira là où il va mais
ça n'est pas son manque d'habitude que
d'aller sur les terrains moi j'ai passé
pendant la semaine de commémoration du
centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale
j'ai passé de longs moments avec le
président de la république à discuter
avec les élus sur les territoires ça a
été quelque chose de très de très bien
et de très intéressant et je vous
signale que cette semaine comme vous le
savez il a reçu 2000 maires à l'elysée
il a fait un discours au je dirais deux
allées 20 minutes et le reste du temps
c'est à dire à peu près deux heures et
demie ça a été des échanges extrêmement
constructif entre les élus c'est ce
qu'il faut qu'ils reproduisent mais il
croit que c'est important que le
président de la république est un
contact physique
je dirais avec les françaises face à la
grogne des laudes mais en haut des
convecteurs connectés mais ce que dit
bruno roux comparagroup 14
en fait vous tirer toujours des
conclusions de ce que les gens disent
le président de la république est sans
arrêt sur le territoire moi j'arrête pas
de l'accompagner sur des déplacements en
province et sur différents sujets donc
il est très au contact des territoires
avec vous l'auriez vu en direct
peut-être que vous n'étiez pas là je ne
sais pas à l'elysée vous avez vu comment
il connaît les territoires et
possessions de collobrières on a comme
l'impression que emmanuel macron à n'a
pas anticipé ce mouvement d'aidé gilet
jaune qui pour le coup a été exploité
récupérer dans meilleur sens du terme
par différentes oppositions
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire lorsque
marine le pen d'une part jean luc
mélenchon d'autre part voir les
républicains se mettre en première ligne
juste derrière les gilet jaune
vous trouvez ça vaut aussi responsable
ou est-ce que c'est pas une légitimité
d'homme politique
ça me conforte dans l'idée que
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen sont
souvent d'accord parce que c'est pas la
première fois la même chose c'est pas la
première fois que je vois cela laisse
pas quand il y a eu les perquisitions
chez monsieur mélenchon je me souviens
des applaudissements de monsieur de
madame le pen pardon quand monsieur
mélenchon
à
contre cette intervention
quelle conclusion vous en tirez vous de
martin un parfum à l'italienne bien
évidemment il ya effectivement un parfum
qui ressemble un peu à l'italie vous
avez raison et il y à une exploitation
quand même politique qui se fait c'est
évident l'opposition en profite quand le
gouvernement a je dirais des opposants
dans la rue des manifestants dans la rue
évidemment les forces politiques
d'opposition s'en emparent pour vous
devrez indiquer lisez aussi la faire
parce que c'est plus pratique d'avoir le
fn et la france est soumise en face que
d'avoir le parti socialiste où les
républicains n'ont coûté mois dans il
faut jamais se réjouir d'avoir les
extrêmes qui progresse à une question
qui me paraît et tout le monde le dit
maintenant est-ce que la suppression
d'une partie de l'impôt sur la fortune a
été bien expliquer parce que dans les
discours et dans les propos des gilet
jaune
on entend souvent oui mais ils en ont
finalement ils ont favorisé les riches
peut-être que cette mesure qui a été
prise tôt au début du quinquennat a été
un signe qui n'a pas été suffisamment
expliqué ou équilibré peut-être parce
que là vous parlez toujours de pédagogie
mais l'on parle de mesurer ce qu'il
aurait fallu dans le même temps prendre
d'autres mesures il faut revenir là
dessus mais d'autres mesures ont été
prises
oui mais revenons sur une mesure de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation qui
est une mesure voulue par le président
de la république comme une mesure
sociale bien évidemment parce que on
parle toujours du débat concernant les
collectivités territoriales si bien
qu'on en a oublié la pertinence
d'origine si je puis dire c'est à dire
au fond faire un geste sur un impôt qui
était devenu très inégale très
inégalitaire même et qui va pour 80% des
habitants permettent évidemment
un avantage en retrait ce phare du début
du quinquennat scully fc infligé
d'autres c'est pour le maire de cenon
j'ai pas dit ça c'est la question j'ai
dit que j'ai dis simplement que ça pu
être mal compris et pas suffisamment
expliqué pascal attendent toujours qu'on
sait très bien que derrière il ya la
volonté de ramener les investisseurs en
france a vu ce qu'il n'y ait pas une
fuite des capitaux à l'extérieur tout le
monde sait ça mais voilà service elle
pas finalement parce que le but c'était
justement que dans les riches il allait
réinvestir il allait injecter de
l'argent dans le circuit de l'économie
française et on n'en voit pas il aurait
atteint il y a eu des investissements en
france
il y a eu des créations d'emplois
industriels mais il faudrait qu'il y en
ait encore plus bien évidemment
pour en revenir au gilet jaune est ce
que le gouvernement a raison ou auraient
raison de recevoir des porte parole des
représentants c'est un mouvement très
nouveau 13 inédits pas vraiment
structuré est-ce que des porte parole
plus ou moins autoproclamés ou élus ou
désignés par l'insee qui aurait une
légitimité à discuter avec un
gouvernement ce que c'est la bonne
méthode finalement je ne sais pas parce
que justement c'est vous saoule dans
votre question vous exprimer justement
qui représente il exactement
encore une fois il y à une telle
diversité de personnes mais moi je crois
que de toute façon quand on a une partie
de la population qui demande à discuter
il faut toujours les écouter est ce que
vous êtes optimiste pour l'avenir
après la déclaration du président de la
république demain parce que vous n'avez
pas répondu à la première personne et
non plus sur la sortie de crise oui ou
non comment on sort de là j'espère que
dans le dialogue où l'on espère par le
dialogue des six le les français vont
comprendre oui qu' il ya des français
aussi je me dis gentiment mais qui sont
un peu exaspéré aussi d'être retenu à
des ronds-points ne pas pouvoir être à
l'heure au travail des commerçants moi
j'ai reçu un mail de la présidente des
commerçants de blois où j'habite et elle
m'a fait pas du déficit enregistré
depuis deux week end et elle m'a dit bon
notre vie est en danger notre vie de
commerçant est en danger on sait pas si
on va pouvoir continuer et c'est une
commerçante qui a des salariés etc
donc il faut aussi que les gilet jaune
se rendent compte que c'est toute
l'économie française qui peut être
perturbé et ça ne le fera
ça ne donnera pas de solution à leurs
problèmes il faut donc que shark 15 ans
sans doute assumer que de perturber
l'économie précisément c'est peut-être
un but assumé mais alors un but qui veut
mener à quoi il ya même une remise en
cause longtemps
de la démocratie représentative après
voilà vous êtes en train de donner de
l'eau au moulin à ceux qui disent que
quand même il n'y a pas que des gens
mécontents qui ont des difficultés
sociales
il ya aussi des gens qui à l'intérieur
de tout cela on des intentions bien sûr
de déstabilisation politique et de la
société vous redoutez une nouvelle
manifestation sur les champs elysées
samedi avec comme mot d'ordre macro
démission et si je redoute
oui je veux dire j'ai vu passer le mot
d'ordre je n'ai pas de réponse à cela
pourrait simplement j'aimerais dire que
ça ne se reproduise font les
interressent commence je sais comment
dire
c'est mauvais pour le pays et même
mauvais pour ceux qui voudraient
interdire interdire les champs-elysées
tout simplement boucler les champs
elysées demandez à monsieur castaner de
boucler cette artère c'est le président
de la république qui en la matière
décidera ce qu'il pense devoir faire
merci merci messieurs voilà c'est
l'heure de la seconde partie de la
deuxième partie d'auditions publiques
maintenant avec nos deux parlementaires
qui font leur entrée sur le plateau
nous donc le sénateur et leur de
l'ardèche mathieu darnaud qui était sur
les points de blocage ce week-end vous
avez quant à douter avec votre voiture
et le député socialiste du val-de-marne
le carbonate
on se remet sur une question des
internautes la du figaro est ce que vous
ne pensez pas jacqueline gourault qu'il
faudrait une question globale réduire
les taxes il a beaucoup de demandes sur
ce sujet même si gérald darmanin dont il
va être beaucoup question dans un
instant dit location vide bcd taxe est
une demande
oui alors on comprend bien qu'il faille
fakih y ait des demandes de baisser les
taxes sont toutes périodes tout le monde
demande a baissé les taxes et il y a de
l'autre côté les politiques publiques
qu'il faut appliquer et donc c'est
toujours cet équilibre qu'il faut
rechercher et c'est ça le la ligne de
crête
si je puis dire sur laquelle tout
gouvernement se trouve
et donc voilà ma réponse alors le
carbonate première question à la
ministre
oui madame la ministre bon soir
justement précisément vous dites il faut
faire attention vis-à-vis de la taxe et
les politiques publiques que l'on met on
regarde précisément le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe avec une proposition
du président macron a souhaité supprimer
la taxe d'habitation dans les faits
vitrifiés attaque david d'habitation on
le comprend bien
et aujourd'hui ce même gouvernement
prend des décisions je prends par
exemple dans le cas du plan pauvreté
quand on propose la prise en charge à 1
euros le repas ce sont les collectivités
territoriales que le fond j'ai fait un
petit calcul dans une ville comme la
mienne c'est une dépense de
fonctionnement supplémentaire de 1,3
million d'euros
aujourd'hui on sort et je vais être bref
du congrès des maires où on l'a souvent
rappelé un maire sur deux aujourd'hui
s'interroge de savoir s'il se représente
ou pas parce que madame la ministre
c'est pas de votre fait aujourd'hui on
est dans un flou artistique de ce grand
soir de fiscalité locale qu'on nous
annonce pour le printemps prochain
oh moi ce que je j'entends c'est que
pour compenser finalement c'est 27
milliards d'euros que l'état doit
trouver pour compenser la suppression
pour tous de la taxe d'habitation
il serait question à chercher sur la
taxe foncière sur les produits bâti pour
les départements et serait question même
que l'état se fasse lui-même les poches
sur les cotisations cgtv à un moment
donné le jeu de bonneteau
je ne vois pas bien comment mais vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs le 11 janvier 2018
qu' il fallait garder un lien entre la
collectivité le contribuable et l'impôt
après vous avez certainement un peu
rétro pédaler pardon vous et de revenus
sur vos propos en tous les cas
aujourd'hui les maires et les élus
locaux ne savent absolument quoi ne
savent pas du tout dans quoi on va
avancer
face à cette suppression de la taxe
d'habitation alors ça fait toujours
plaisir à nos administrés
moi je me souviens il ya un an au moment
du projet de loi de finances je disais à
la nouvelle majorité n'opposer pas le
pouvoir d'achat de nos administrés à la
qualité de nos services publics et je
crois que l'association des maires de
france
quand elle demande comme moi le 1 1 euro
pour 1 euro que l'état dit vouloir
confirmer et bien de cette suppression
de la taxe d'habitation à minima soit
indexé d'une année sur l'autre à
l'inflation elle sent que la question au
père de large la question c'est d'une
demande d'éclaircissements alors vous
allez faire livrer à un jeu de bonneteau
fiscales donc on prend dans une poche on
en met dans une autre et alors camembert
dans l'intervention de monsieur
carvounas d'abord en ce qui concerne le
plan pauvreté que vous avez évoqué au
début et le repas à 1 euro c'était un
exemple qui a été citée car vous savez
bien que le plan pauvreté se base sur au
fond une politique contractuelle avec
les collectivités locales qui seront
volontaires et à partir du moment où les
collectivités locales seront volontaires
un département une intercommunalité
il y aura sur les compétences du
département ou de l'intercommunalité un
accompagnement de l'état
c'est ça le plan pauvreté ensuite c'est
un exemple avec comme l'ouverture des
médiathèques le dimanche
qui va payer ensuite deuxième point vous
avez parlé de la taxe d'habitation la
taxe d'habitation vous le savez bien que
c'est un un morceau du programme d'un
engagement du président de la république
et que il a basé son raisonnement sur le
fait que cet impôt était devenu très
inégalitaire et vous savez pourquoi
nous savons tous que les bases n'ont
jamais été
revalorisé depuis 1971 il le fait et
vous savez que les communes seront
compensées pendant trois années
alors c'est pas 27 milliards ces 20
milliards ensuite par quoi cela sera
meilleur qu'à ses 25 ans
tous ces demandes concernant les 10
milliards chez madame la lettre les
premiers des médias sont inscrits dans
la trajectoire budgétaire de délégués
chinois demandent les dix premiers
milliards sont inscrits dans la
trajectoire budgétaire vous me disais où
allez-vous les prendre je vous réponds
dans les poches des terrassonnais
ensuite deuxième point deuxième point
vont me poser la question de savoir ce
qui se passera après il se passera après
comme quand la part salaires sur la
veille l'atp avait été supprimée ou
quand la tp a été supprimé totalement
raté cet événement cette affection la
taxe professionnelle on voulait rassurer
les élus en disant qu'ils n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas à s'inquiéter on a face
à lui je m'attaque professeur c'est le
trône exemple les parages un autre sujet
aux pensées mathieu darnaud alors du
tout ce qui se passe vous entre le sénat
et puis le gouvernement est
spécifiquement gérald darmanin puisque à
la suite d'un tweet vengeur du ministre
le sénat a protesté puisque on vous a
accusé d'ailleurs tous unanimes sur tous
les bancs d'avoir accordé un avantage
fiscal aux élus aux minutes
mr je précisais quand même corriger tous
les bancs ont voté c'est ce que je vis
tout seul amendement alors et le le
souhait c'était de dire quoi c'était de
dire qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement ne
veut pas nous tenir un double discours
de dire je viens on appuie justement et
je restaure le débat et le dialogue avec
les élus locaux et sur un léger avantage
quand même qui existait auparavant et
qui permettait quand même non pas de
donner un avantage en monnaie sonnante
et trébuchante aux élus simplement de
faire en sorte qu'ils aient via cette
exonération les moyens de financer une
part de leurs frais de déplacement une
part de tout ce qui est inhérent à
l'exercice de leur mandat
juste un chiffre parce que c'est
tellement éclairant quand on stigmatise
les maires un maire d'une commune de
moins de 500 habitants et ils sont
légion sur nos territoires
sap
soit par mois 660 euros bruts aux
raccords de la merci qu'est-ce que 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 vous dites
allemand est ce que je veux dire
et jean monnet sap ces efforts je
considère que monsieur darmanin seraient
avisés d'être un peu plus dans la
modération plutôt que dans l'excès et
surtout surtout la question que je pose
à jacqueline gourault elle est toute
simple c'est que j'entends que le
président reçoit 2000 mer mais il refuse
alors qu'il s'était engagé de venir
devant le congrès des maires qu'on a eu
un échec cuisant de la conférence
nationale des territoires que toutes les
associations d'élus ont tourné le dos
c'est comment justement on met en place
cette nouvelle méthode de dialogue parce
que pour faire un dialogue il faut être
deux c'est souvent ce que je dis faire
mathieu darnaud je suis heureux d'abord
un vous savez que je n'ai jamais
stigmatisé un seul maire de ma vie c'est
le premier point le deuxième point alors
que votre différence avec un de vos
collègues et je marque ma différence
avec personne deuxième point je voulais
revenir sur ce que vous disiez vous
savez que le sujet en question provient
au fond de la fiscalisation des
indemnités des élus fiscalisation
globale qui a été voté monsieur cavour
n'a sous l'ancien gouvernement
un peu en catimini c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui
l'indemnité représentative de frais de
mandat est aussi dans sa grosse partie
fiscalisés
j'ai travaillé avec le sénat dans le
cadre de la délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et nous avons évoqué ce
sujet et naturellement
personnellement j'ai dit qu'on étudie
reis sujet mais dans un cadre global et
attend ce dans un cadre global avec la
couverture sociale avec la protection
aussi juridique qui est très importante
avec des protections aussi dans les
arrêts maladie etc va mal et trop loin
donc c'est quelque chose qui faisait
partie d'un cadre d'accords dont nous
étions en négociation at the parler
d'eux dans ce cadre-là du statut des
élus ce sujet qui vous intéresse que ce
cas vous ne sais pas
nous le sénat préfère dire faciliter
l'exercice ce sont des oies la cellule
j'ai pas fini tout à fait ma réponse est
donc il est clair qu'il faut reprendre
cette négociation comme elle était
prévue et quand le
l'amendement a été passé et mathieu
darnaud le sait bien
l'amendement qui a été passée couvrent
tout le champ des collectivités
territoriales et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a une volonté du
gouvernement avec le sénat de renégocier
de le réécrire
oui pour que cela concerne une catégorie
et notamment les plus petites dont par
les parents des concerts 15e du mal à
tomber dans les excès v2 mais le tweet
dans son contenu n'était pas vous pouvez
le reconnaître différents d'un fait
aller alors soit je vois dans les
maisons pour le dire ça lorsqu'il est
sûr c'est que ce tweet du ministre est
moins violente le hashtag balances ton
mère qui l'a mis en oeuvre en
stigmatisant les élus locaux
je vous reconnais madame la ministre
vous avez interpellé lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement cette
question vous avez totalement avec
beaucoup de l'été intellectuelle dénoncé
ce hashtag balances ton mère qui était
organisé par des permanents de la
république en marche pour préciser les
choses
ensuite pour ce qui est du statut de
l'élu je vous reconnais aussi d'avoir il
ya quelques années j'étais au sénat à
vos côtés avec un rapport avec jean
pierre sueur commencé à poser le débat
sur le statut de l'élu les conditions
d'activité pour les luttes dans les
petites communes je poste un premier
galop d'essai il faut maintenant aller
jusqu'au bout y avoir l'honnêteté de
poser débat sur la démocratie elle a un
coup ici on veut pardon avoir des mers
et dans nos conseils municipaux les
visages de la société et pas que des
professions libérales ou des hauts
fonctionnaires
il faut aussi permettre les va et vient
entre l'engagement de l'intérêt général
et la vie professionnelle
aujourd'hui les élus sont sans fil et
moi je vais vous dire il ya même dans le
statut les lieux actuellement quand on
est ouvrier soit disant si le maire fait
une inde au cul mans pour l'employeur
l'employeur laisse son employé c'est pas
vrai j'ai été maire vous savez bien les
employeurs ne lâche pas les conseillers
municipaux pour venir participer aux
instances paritaires
nous avons tout un programme à faire
ensemble pour accompagner les élus dans
l'exercice de leur mandat c'est c'est
très important et il faut penser aussi à
la formation il faut penser à la sortie
de mandat aussi parce qu'il ya des gens
qui sortent de mandat qui se retrouve
sans rien et enfin pour les indemnités
moi j'avais fait passer même une loi au
sénat
quand j'étais sénatrice pour que dans
les communes de moins de 1000 habitants
les indemnités soit automatique parce
que vous savez la première délibération
comprend après une élection c'est
l'indemnité du maire
et désormais c'est automatique dans les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants
alors messieurs d'arnaud vous avez
publié un rapport récemment avec trente
mesures pour revaloriser la commune on
va parler quand même de la transition
énergétique écologistes puisque vous
êtes un élu rural et vous avez écouté la
ministre dans la première partie de
l'émission
vous avez envie de réagir sur sa réponse
d'abord et sur la réponse que vous vous
attendez également du chef de l'état oui
mais vous savez je crois beaucoup à la
différenciation territoriale je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on touche du doigt un
exemple de différenciation territoire
moi je viens d'un département est ce que
je dis est très concret aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas faire trop voiturage
on a pas de transports publics urbains
de l'ardèche avancé l'ardèche on est une
zone de montagne l'hiver c'est difficile
d'avoir une voiture électrique et les
batteries aujourd'hui ne permettent pas
des déplacements - jeudi dans ces zones
là les habitants sont obligés d'avoir
recours paul travaille à la voiture est
ce que je regrette dans le débat actuel
c'est qu'on ne dénonce pas suffisamment
la supercherie parce que tout le monde
le sait c'est qu'aujourd'hui
luc carvounas en parlais tout à l'heure
sur la taxe d'habitation
on est aujourd'hui sur cette hausse des
carburants pour combler fiscalement
cette problématique là on sait très bien
que toutes les recettes de la hausse des
carburants n'iront pas à la transition
écologique on le sait ça a été démontrée
et il suffit de regarder le budget pour
cent combattants quelques la mise de la
partie parce que la ministre un démenti
à apporter à ce que vous n'êtes mer ou
que nous verrons si appétissante parce
qu'il suffit de regarder
le g20 finances a convaincu non mais la
transition énergétique et les
prélèvements comme vous dites il était
très difficile parce qu'au fond ça
concerne plein de politiques publiques
ça ne va pas un seul endroit par exemple
quand vous dites la pollution les
particules fines c'est des problèmes de
santé
j'entends bien donc ça va convenir que
d'arnaud que je connais bien c'est un
peu simpliste là du tout mais son but
mais si c'est le fait simpliste et puis
d'autre part je suis d'accord avec vous
par contre sur la différenciation c'est
même un des points que nous avons
inscrit dans la constitution l'article
72 où on inscrit le droit à la
différenciation parce que dans leur
tâche c'est à dire qu'il faut adapter
les solutions aux territoires
c'est ça qu'il veut dire et moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec cela
c'est quelque chose de très important et
c'est aussi pour ça que dans la future
loi
l'homme que va présenter la ministre des
transports elle propose qu'il y ait une
adaptation au fond des modes de
transport en fonction de tous les
territoires et surtout peu tous les
territoires puissent trouver un mode de
transport
la mobilité l'alba est présente à moi
j'attends voir parce que la mobilité
dans des territoires ruraux et
aujourd'hui des gilet jaune c'est
beaucoup sur ce sujet là d'un mobilité
parce que finalement la hausse des
carburants c'est ça avant tout c'est la
problématique de mona lisa
les dernières marches et l'incapacité à
travailler juste d'un mot excuse et noir
par rapport aux débats précédents sur la
transition écologique je pense que les
français sont pas dupes et je crois que
la modification de la du trans de la
trajectoire de la taxe carbone telle
qu'elle était inscrite dans la loi de
2015 que nous avons votée n'est pas le
même esprit aujourd'hui où d'ici 2022
l'état veut récupérer 55 milliards
d'euros dont 40 % 40 % vont dans les
caisses de l'état parce qu'il ya
justement cette problématique des 27
milliards d'euros notamment liée à la th
à devoir compenser un moment donné les
temps faut bien qu'elle trouve qu'il
trouve l'argent quelque part et enfin je
m'interroge juste sur une des
propositions que l'on a déjà annoncé du
président demain c'est quoi cette
histoire d'un haut conseil sur le climat
quand ils existent déjà
par le précédent gouvernement un conseil
national de la transition écologique il
existe le 16e qu'il existe que la
commission développement durable de
l'assemblée nationale la commission
développement durable du sénat qu'est ce
que c'est que cette carabistouille qu on
nous invente pour agiter un nouveau
chiffon en faisant croire aux français
venez autour de la table embrassons nous
folleville et on vous a compris pas ça
marche pas comme ça les français ils ont
bien compris qu'on est en train de se
fiche de réponse mais c'est qu'avant
nacelle quelque chose vraiment qui est
très difficile à admettre dans ce que
vous venez de faire c'est au fond de
dire que le gouvernement enfin vous
réduisez l'action du gouvernement à une
affaire strictement financière oui
madame
eh bien je regrette de madame valls à
vos parents pour les plus riches
trois cent soixante trois mille foyers
fiscaux les plus riches de ce pays
5 milliard de roubles 25 milliards sur
internet la réponse monsieur carvounas
vous savez très bien qu'il ya des
problèmes de santé en france que la
pollution tue en france
beaucoup de gens chaque année il est
d'accord vous le savez on aide à
conserver qu'il faut faire la transition
énergétique parce qu'il ya aussi le
réchauffement de la planète et vous
savez tous que ça engendre et vous
réduisez slam une histoire financière
rapports avec les bercy qui dirige
gouvernement madame je le dis et je le
répète question suivante alors que je
voulais pas répondre je ne réponds pas
aux excès vous aviez tout à l'heure
qu'il n'y avait pas deux camps dans le
gouvernement c'est pas bercy des techno
et de l'autre des élus ou des ministres
qui viennent du modem au nom de
l'humanisme revendiquée par françois
bayrou c'était la réponse tout à l'heure
non mais je comprends monsieur d'arnaud
non-jeu revenir sur la réforme
territoriale
moi j'entends ce qui est dit et en même
temps je crains malheureusement que ce
haut conseil ne soit finalement que la
suite de ce qu'on a connu dans la
conférence nationale des territoires je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut être
concret pragmatique
moi je redoute votre expression tout est
sur la table parce qu elle m'amène à
penser et à me poser la question comment
allons-nous être mangé moi je le dis
nous avons rendu un rapport vous avez
fait référence à un allié sûr
les conditions d'exercice des élus j'ai
rendu avec la commission des lois un
rapport 30 mesures pour revitaliser la
commune je pense qu'il est beaucoup plus
efficace et efficient de partir de
propositions concrètes telles que nous
les avons posées et vous êtes venus même
conclure le colloque
donc à partir de là avant sont plutôt
que d'aller ré inventer des choses qui
existent parce que les solutions les
connais quand on parle du principe
qu'ils décident paye quand on dit qu'il
faut sanctuariser la clause de
compétence générale pour que les
communes continuent à vivre ça c'est des
éléments qui sont concrets et qui
m'amène à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a les
éléments sur la table
donc continuons et avançons ensemble
plutôt que de réinventer des lieux qui
sont finalement des lieux de passage est
engagé je crois
mathieu darnaud que je suis aussi une
contracté qu'à chaque fois il y a eu des
sujets des problèmes à régler j'ai été
là et je ne cesse de travailler avec le
sénat sur tous les sujets que vous venez
d'annoncer de façon très bien vague
matinée au premier ministre et à
l'ensemble des savants c'est con mais le
premier ministre est aussi pragmatique
c'est un à l'ancien maire il s'est
résigné à matisse que ses collègues de
pramac pragmatique et donc vous savez
très bien que le congrès des maires
j'espère en tout cas puisque monsieur
baroin a dit qu'il fallait à nouveau
entrés dans une période de dialogue nous
espérons que les maires seront enfin
l'association des maires de france sera
autour de la table pour parler de tous
les dossiers que vous voulez voir
avancer parce que vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure quand on dialogue il faut être
deux et pour avancer il faut que le
parlement aussi soit là pour faire
avancer les dossiers
trente dernières secondes contre le
dialogue il faut et dollars l'occurrence
nous étions trois j'ai constaté au caire
il veut pas toujours répondre quand on
échange à bâtons rompus dit quelque
chose je cours d'après-midi de la
république considère qu'un parlementaire
quand il dit des choses c'est de l'excès
c'est certain mais c'est certainement
aussi je reprends ce que j'ai dit si je
vous suis aperçu à passer mon père me
coûter la parole madame et bien c'est
chose en relation alors je vous en prie
ne faisait pas ne fait pas pardon
l'offusqué on se connaît suffisamment
vous savez très bien que vous avez
réduit
la politique est une politique forte de
transition énergétique de transition
écologique que vous aviez même voté vous
même vous savez très bien des pas moi
maintenant qu'il est rédigé nicolas
hulot lui-même membre de votre gouverne
monsieur car vous ne sont pas là réduire
comme vous l'avez fait mais c'est la
réalité non ça n'est pas une réalité les
bains les gens sont juges
vous vous retrouverez bien sûr très vite
pour dialoguer merci beaucoup monsieur
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
vous renvoie maintenant dans les
coulisses pour la suite puisque vous
allez céder vos places à deux
journalistes qui font leur entrée
avec donc ariane mancini et ludovic faut
qu'ils nous rejoignent cette question
d'un internaute du figaro live
jacqueline gourault et quelqu'un vous a
écouté attentivement depuis le début
d'audition publique et vous demande
madame gouraud
comment pouvez-vous faire pour faire
bouger le président dans ses certitudes
je crois pas que le président et enfin
il a des convictions je crois pas qu'il
ait des certitudes ce qui voudrait dire
qu'il est fermé à toute réflexion ou qui
n'entendrait pas ce que lui dit la
population ou non donc à ben moi je
discute souvent avec le président de
l'apr de jeu et 13 en direct et le
président de la république a tout à fait
conscience était tout à fait clairvoyant
de ce qu'il voit et je suis sûr que dès
demain notre internaute pourra
l'entendre dorion alors nous aussi on
vous a écouté attentivement avec ludovic
on a quelques précisions sur ce que vous
venez de dire à vous demandez vous venez
à l'instant de parler de l'association
des maires de france quand on dialogue
il faut être deux vous nous avez dit est
ce que ça veut dire que françois baroin
jusqu'à maintenant n'était pas prêt à
dialoguer à bas il ya eu une période où
vous le savez très bien l'association
des maires de france
ne venez pas à la table des discussions
notamment dans la conférence des
territoires donc il faut tourner une
page écrite à l'angle de
l'incompréhension a dit françois baroin
lors du discours de clôture du vous êtes
d'accord d'un j'espère qu'il tourneras
vraiment la page en tout cas nous il y a
longtemps que lui tendons la main
autre précision sur la compensation de
la taxe d'habitation
vous avez commencé à nous expliquer mais
on n'a pas très bien compris le chef de
l'état s'est engagé à la compenser à
l'euro près il a écrit dans sa lettre au
maire est-ce que ça c'est du court terme
sk le prêt il va falloir envisager un
nouvel impôt si j'ai pas répondu
complètement de talent ce qu on me
coupait la parole
une première il ya une première période
où il y aura un dégrèvement c'est à dire
que je fais simple l'état prend la place
du contribuable ça c'est les 3 années de
suppression de la taxe d'habitation et
puis ensuite il y à la période suivante
et bien évidemment c'est une discussion
que nous allons avoir avec toutes les
associations d'élus je sors d'une
discussion avec l'association villes de
france à l'instant sur au fond la
réforme fiscale qu'il faut mettre en
place pour le prolongement de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
donc je n'ai pas aujourd'hui les
solutions puisque on veut négocier avec
les associations d'élus mais il y a
quelques pistes premièrement c'est pas
un nouvel impôt
c'est une répartition nouvelles des
impôts donc pas de nouvel impôt pas de
nouvel impôt
deuxièmement il y a est ce que c'est un
impôt avec capacité de taux ou est ce
que c'est une part d'un impôt national
c'est le deuxième sujet par exemple
comme cela a été fait pour les régions
avec une part de tva
il y a donc plusieurs sujets qui se
posent et il faut qu'on discute qu'on se
mette autour de la table avec toutes les
associations d'élus est ce que le fait
que les trois associations d'élus se
soit uni que régions départements
communes ça ne vous complique pas la
tâche non ça complique palach la tâche
elles discutent entre elles voient bien
rendre à une collectivité pour donner
mais non il faudra bien trouver une
solution ça s'est fait par le passé j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure quand il ya eu
déjà d'autres réformes fiscales on a
bien trouvé des solutions notre grosse
frayeur quand même endroit bien mais il
ya aussi les intercommunalités la dcf
avec qui nous discutons villes de france
france urbaine
il y a beaucoup d'associations on
travaille avec l'ensemble des
associations le dos avec alain boureau
les relations on l'a vu avec les élus
locaux ne sont pas simples les relations
sont tendues aussi ces derniers temps
avec le avec le sénat où la majorité
sénatoriale de droite estiment que la
réforme de la constitution qui dont
l'examen de reprendre
au mois de janvier majorité de droite
donc estime que pas vraiment une
priorité pour les français au moment où
la france gronde
est ce que vous nous dites aujourd'hui
que cette réforme l'examen de cette
forme reprendra bien en début d'année
prochaine
eh bien écoutez je ne sais pas s'il
trouve que ça n'est pas prioritaire mais
mathieu darnaud qui est un sénateur donc
de la majorité sénatoriale a fait tout à
leur référence au droit à la
différenciation en disant qu'il croyait
beaucoup et cela le président du sénat y
croit beaucoup aussi
donc je crois que bien sûr il y avait
d'autres sujets à traiter mais je crois
que la révision constitutionnelle ne
serait ce que pour les territoires donc
ne serait ce que pour le sénat elle doit
arriver vite et puis il ya d'autres
choses dans la révision
constitutionnelle qui sont importantes
par exemple il ya le statut d'accord ce
qui est inscrit dans la constitution ça
fait aussi partie des territoires
le projet c'est 72,5 donc je pense que
des réformes aussi qui sont très
importantes sur le plan juridictionnel
enfin vous savez avec le statut des
procureurs et c'est donc je pense que
c'est une bonne réforme car tout l art
et aux scènes d'action
la question c'est qu'est ce que vous
dites aux sénateurs parce qu'ils n'en
veulent pas ah mais je ne suis pas sûr
que les sénateurs ne veulent pas de la
réforme constitutionnelle on n'est pas
opportun ils disent qu ils ne fassent it
on peut pas dire que le sénat je veux
dire jusqu'ici elle facilite et la
rapidité de comment dire de de l'étude
de la réforme constitutionnelle
mais moi je pense qu'on ne peut pas
indéfiniment dire on est pour le droit à
la différenciation est repoussée parce
que je crois qu'on en a besoin sur les
territoires la france a des territoires
très divers il ya des attentes et on ne
peut pas appliquer les mêmes choses
selon les territoires ruraux et les
grandes métropoles et donc il faut se
donner les moyens de faire évoluer notre
politique pas un paradoxe au moment où
l'exécutif demande aux parlementaires
aux députés de la majorité d'être
davantage présents sur le terrain à
vouloir supprimer justement
diminuer le nombre de parlementaires ce
qui a pas un paradoxe est ce que
finalement les parlementaires de fait ne
sont pas moins présents sur le terrain
pourquoi serait-il moins présent sur le
terrain parce qu'elles sont moins
nombreux c'est ce que je crois je crois
que c'est une erreur parce que son plus
grand serre conscription plus grande
écoutez moi je suis j'étais par foyer
j'étais sénatrice et canton des
sénatrices dans un département rural on
est sénatrice de l'ensemble du
département et on arrive à faire son
travail
évidemment puisque maintenant il ya la
fin du cumul des mandats
évidemment c'était très difficile de le
faire quand vous aviez un mandat local
important mais je crois que il y aura
toujours moyen
vous savez moi j'ai je pense quelque
chose de très simple je pense qu'il ya
des gens qui ont le sens du terrain qui
ont le sens que être parlementaire
c'est marcher sur ses deux jambes c'est
à dire faire être présent au parlement
et être sur le terrain trouver
l'équilibré puis à des gens n'est ce pas
qui ne savent pas trouver l'équilibré
ç'a toujours été comme ça et je pense
que il faut faire attention quand on
veut vraiment faire bien son travail de
le respecter c'est très fort mais si
importante est ce qu'il faudra aller
jusqu'au référendum en cas de blocage au
sénat
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
l'est républicain au sénat semble vous
dire chiche
bruno retailleau il a tendance à nous
donner beaucoup de conseils ces temps ci
n'est ce pas bruno retailleau il est
président d'un groupe
le groupe plr au sénat il n'est pas de
la majorité
voilà on entend ce qu'il nous dit parce
que il est quelqu'un d'important dans un
groupe par le à la tête d'un groupe
parlementaire adobe
mais je veux dire par là ça n'est pas
lui qui dirige au fond l'action du
gouvernement donc qu'elle vous répondez
vous que répondez-vous simplement à la
question à un référendum chez berg
je réponds que non il ya une majorité
des trois cinquièmes on est dans le
système de majorité en fin de la voie
parlementaire puisque vous parlez des
attentes des élus sur cette réforme
constitutionnelle les élus attendre
notamment l'inscription de l'autonomie
fiscale et financière dans la
constitution vous êtes favorable qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'ils
veulent garantir leurs moyens leur
autonomie
l'autonomie financière et déjà inscrits
pas l'autonomie fiscale
mais l'autonomie fiscale il faut
s'entendre déjà sur la définition de
l'autonomie fiscale
alors il faudra qu'on en parle autour de
la table il y en a des sujets sur le
cacao d'autres sujets la corse puisque
vous êtes madame corse
vous êtes madame alsace également et les
nationalistes corses
eh bien ils disent pourquoi l'alsace à
une reconnaissance de sa langue
pourquoi l'alsace à une reconnaissance
de sa dimension historique et le
gouvernement ne nous la corde pas s'il
ya deux poids deux mesures oui alors
qu'on peut dire tout et n'importe quoi
c'est c'est possible dans notre pays la
seule
enfin la seule décision fera pas
décision dans le protocole d'accord
entre les alsaciens et le gouvernement
nous avons travaillé sur le bilinguisme
c'est à dire l'apprentissage et
l'enseignement de la langue allemande
c'est à dire les alsaciens évidemment
vous comprenez ça très bien pour
travailler dans les entreprises
allemandes qui sont soit sur le
territoire alsace revient soit juste de
l'autre côté du rhin faut que les jeunes
connaissent l'allemand donc il s'agit de
l'allemand oui c'est bien ils livrent
d'ailleurs ils vous avaient été
interrogés un par le député jean félix
acquaviva à ce sujet à l'assemblée
nationale donc pour vous il n'ya pas
deux poids deux mesures mais nous sommes
sur une langue l'apprentissage d'une
langue c'est comme la peau sur les
aliments sur le jura
du trilinguisme au luxembourg je rajoute
l'anglais il parle anglais de la
direction historique du compromis
politique qui a été fait avec les élus
et qui visiblement ce n'est pas le dit
ce n'est pas le cas encore s'ils disent
d'ailleurs les nationaliser ce n'est pas
le temps comme ça n'a rien à voir
les corses après l'allemand s'ils le
veulent l'anglais du compromis politique
également qui a été fait avec les élus
des discussions qui ont été faits avec
les élus mais ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que vous savez sûrement que la
corse est une collectivité à statut
particulier
premier point 2e - nous allons inscrire
ce particularisme dans la constitution
sont 60 12-5 ce qui était demandé par
les corses depuis fort longtemps que je
sache nous avons passé un accord avec
les alsaciens mais qui n'est ni une
collectivité à statut particulier qui ne
sera non plus pas écrite dans la
constitution
il ya dans comment dire l'explication
fait parler corse quelque chose d'un peu
curieux non j'en appelle à gauche et
vous êtes un mois de décembre
j'y vais au mois de décembre et aux
vrais décors va faire de la pédagogie
je leur ai déjà souvent expliqué voilà
bon elle amène un autre sujet un autre
dossier qui concerne votre ministère le
logement à marseille au début du mois
trois immeubles se sont effondrés
huit morts depuis plus de 180 immeubles
ont été évacués ça représente plus de
1300 personnes
est ce qu'il ya eu des manquements de la
part de la ville on sait que des
dizaines de millions de subventions de
la région de l'europe n'ont pas été
utilisés ou réclamer pour rénover
l'habitat insalubre des manquements de
la ville les manquements de l'état aussi
est ce que le préfet n'aurait pas dû
prendre le relais en voyant qu'ils
avaient peut-être un problème de
logement dangereux à marseille il y a
effectivement des logements insalubres
a marseille il y avait eu cet accident
dramatique qui a fait
huit morts ce qui est quelque chose
d'épouvantable et je crois qu'il faut
toujours penser à ceux qui ont perdu un
des leurs et le gouvernement accompagne
la ville et la métropole
je dirais dans le traitement de cette de
ceux de cet événement qui comme vous
venez de le rappeler a fait que à peu
près mille quatre cents personnes ont
été évacuées de logements soit certains
sont partis dans leur famille mais il y
a à peu près 800 personnes qui ont été
relogés dans des hôtels
le préfet a été évidemment très présent
et toutes les les services de l'état ou
accompagné la mairie et la métropole
deuxièmement un guichet unique a été
créé la femme créée par le préfet pour
faciliter toutes les démarches pour les
gens et puis troisièmement nous avons
envoyé des spécialistes aussi pour
accompagner les fonctionnaires
municipaux pour l'évaluation des risques
des maisons qui sont potentiellement je
travaille mais là il ya des choses qui
sortent que rappelle ludovic c'est quand
même incroyable de découvrir que la
ville de marseille avait à portée de
main des millions d'euros de subventions
de la région de l'union européenne les
ont laissé passer pour lutter contre
l'habitat insalubre mais ce que vous
jugez cet état de fait le gouvernement
c'est mon prédécesseur jacques mézard
qui a signé en décembre de l'année
dernière
tout un programme contre le logement
insalubre et aussi deuxièmement une
deuxième étape de l'anru c'est à dire de
renouvellement
de l'habitat urbain une première étape
avait été déjà faite sur 13 ou 14
quartiers la case quartier étaient
envisagées dont le quartier où est
arrivé l'accident et a donc une action
d'état avec la de ce qu'est une incurie
tél vous savez quand ils arrivent
toujours c'est dramatique accident
on peut toujours s'interroger sur ce qui
a été fait pas fait a suffisamment fait
il y a eu des décisions qui ont été
prises notamment
vous savez que l'état comme les mairies
peuvent prendre et d d d arrêter
tergiverser et cela avait été pris sur
une partie du débat qui les y avait à
votre place il ya quinze jours le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel bancaires qui nous a annoncé ici
qu'il allait ordonner un audit des
écoles marseillaise parce que elle aussi
elle mme nasreen elles prennent l'eau
est ce que vous vous allez peut-être je
ne sais pas demandé un audit de la ville
de marseille nous sommes aux côtés de la
ville de marseille pour et de la
métropole pour prévenir il y à aussi
vous savez tout un programme qui a été
lancé dans la loi élan qui vise à lutter
contre les marchands de sommeil parce
que ça c'est aussi très important il
faut taper au portefeuille je dirais des
marchands de sommeil
et puis toute une une politique aussi
d'initiatives sur la propriété privée ça
c'est quelque chose de très important
soit le grade des particules alors est
celle du baryum oui concernant logement
l'encadrement des loyers
la ville de paris va rétablir
l'encadrement des loyers ce que vous
encourager d'autres villes à le faire
c'est sur le volontariat
et c'est une expérimentation et on verra
bien sûr ce que cela donne alors vous
savez que l'encadrement des loyers s'est
limité la hausse trop rapide
1 voilà mais c'est une expérimentation
et sur le volontariat mais l'état jouera
le jeu parce qu'une fois que la mairie
aura pris cette décision ferait que le
préfet justement fixe un loyer plafond
au mètre carré
il ya un certain nombre de décisions qui
dépendent de l'état avec des décrets
aussi qu'ils seront à prendre l'état
jouera le jeu sur ce sujet mme sûr ça se
fera en collaboration avec la ville de
paris bien sûr morgan autre sujet la loi
de 1905 sur la séparation de l'église et
de l'état emmanuel macron envisage de la
modifier on sait que c'est un sujet qui
peut être explosif un sujet à manier
avec précaution et ce qu'il ira jusqu'au
bout je les dis j'ai déjà répondu à
cette question
attention attention prudence danger mais
je dirais que c'est quelque chose qui
est un socle de notre société
je rappelle que la loi de 1905 qui a été
voté après des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années de discussion que c'est là
aussi la voix modérées qui a été trouvé
quand cette loi a été votée c'est une
loi d' équilibre sur laquelle repose
notre laïcité
alors certains font remarquer qu'elle a
déjà été modifié mais elle a été
modifiée sur des détails
et comme dirait le président du sénat
d'une main tremblante
moi je suis de celles qui disent il faut
faire vraiment attention à ce que le
grand principe de la laïcité c'est à
dire la liberté
bien sûr religieuse n'est ce pas mais
c'est la preuve la primauté de la nuit
les cités qui doit et vous les conseille
pas y toucher
je ne donne pas de conseils de ne pas y
toucher les enfants comme un boulot dès
que je dis qu'il faut être très prudent
d'accord mais vous nous dites que
même si la place de l'islam grandi dans
notre pays on n'est pas obligé de
changer la loi de 1905 il ya des lois
existantes
je crois qu'il faut respecter les grands
équilibres de la loi de 1905
je vais la pma est ce que vous diriez
aussi attention prudence
le gouvernement semble avoir décidé de
temporiser un petit peu on attendait un
texte pour la fin de l'année finalement
ce sera ce sera plutôt en début d'année
le président de la république néanmoins
se serait engagé à la semaine dernière
en recevant des associations à ce que
cette loi soit bien déposer voté
promulgué même en 2019 est ce que vous
nous confirmez ce calendrier est ce que
vous y êtes favorable je confirme ce
calendrier ce sera au début de l'année
2019 je n'ai pas la date exacte mais ce
sera au début de l'année 2019 c'est un
sujet important en tout cas ce que je
peux dire c'est qu'il faudra veiller à
écouter tout le monde parce que on a vu
trop par le passé qu'on écoutait pas
tout le monde et je pense que faut
écouter les opposants les opposants
doivent être écoutés passe en fait morte
et je n'ai pas dit que j'allais j'en
faisais partie de cette question non gm
a pour tout mais il faut oui à pma n'est
pas la gpa dans la justice il faut aussi
écouter tout le monde parce que la
société n'est pas une elle l'a des
courants il faut l'écouter comme dans
d'autres domaines
parce que je remarque souvent que ont
fait des reproches à certains de ne pas
écouter certains mouvements et sur
d'autres sujets il y a une vision
monolithique qu'on voudrait imposer de
mesures mais vous vous la mine et de la
cohésion des territoires vous dit
attention c'est un sujet qui peut
fracturé la société
je ne dis pas que c'était un sujet parce
que je crois que la société a évolué
pour l'amener à d'autres là est tout le
monde peut évoluer
voilà et la société a évolué et je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui est
maintenant compris mais il faudra aussi
bien expliquer et faire attention que la
crainte de la gpa n'apparaissent pas
derrière
dernière question henry dernier mot pour
finir sur françois bayrou qui se fait
entendre en ce moment françois bayrou il
toujours tendre avec les ministres de
droite est donc le premier ministre est
ce que françois bayrou vous le voyez
premier ministre dans une seconde partie
de quinquennat écouter vraiment c'est la
dernière question est bien coûter
réfléchissant 11 ans on verra ça tard
j'ai lu un formidable portrait de vous
dans le journal du dimanche où il est
dit notamment que vous depuis 30 ans
vous avez françois bayrou deux fois par
jour vous l'avez déjà eu une première
fois aujourd'hui
eh bien non vous avez encore aujourd'hui
vous vous apprêtez à lui parlé deux fois
alors je suis dans la soirée je le mets
sur mon tout à leur va bien il vous aura
regardé avec nous ce soir merci beaucoup
j'ai un gros merci à vous bon soir à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]
lcp le mag
c'est dans un instant
ce 16 juin 1940 il doit prendre la
décision la plus difficile de sa vie
refusé la défaite et entamer de
l'étranger la reconquête de la france en
juin 1940 comment de gaulle alors
inconnu ou presque est il entré dans
l'histoire ne cherchons à comprendre
avec mes invités dont le journaliste et
auteur laurent joffrin droit de suite
présenté par jean-pierre gratien ce soir
à 20h30 mcdf vous présente solidairement
votre être solidaire c'est permettre à
ceux qui veulent passer leurs vieux
jours chez eux de rester autonome le
plus longtemps possible
selon professeur jean dell ce n'est pas
large qu'il faut prendre en compte pour
prévenir la perte d'autonomie
fonctionnelle mais l'identification des
facteurs de fragilité
facteur qui ne sont pas uniquement
médicaux mais aussi sociaux ou liées à
l'habitat comme la précarité ou encore
l' isolement
[Musique]
pour cela il faut comprendre qu'il
existe trois modalités d'avancé en
argent la première c'est la catégorie
dite robuste la personne âgée garde ses
capacités fonctionnelles très longtemps
elle reste capable d'accomplir les
gestes de la vie quotidienne comme se
déplacer se nourrir assurer son hygiène
c'est ce que l'on appelle un
vieillissement réussi en france cette
catégorie représente environ 25% des
personnes
après 65 ans la deuxième catégorie est
dit fragile
elle concerne les personnes âgées qui
vont perdre en autonomie en raison de
maladies chroniques
cette catégorie représente 25 à 40% des
personnes âgées
il existe une catégorie intermédiaire ce
sont les personnes dites fragilisées
leurs fonctions diminue mais pas en
raison de maladies l'enjeu c'est qu'elle
ne bascule pas dans la catégorie des
personnes fragiles dépendantes
[Musique]
on va alors leur proposer un programme
en quatre axes alimentation pour ne pas
se dénude rien vérifier qu'à sion des
fonctions cognitives et motrices
maintien du lien social pour ne pas
s'isoler et activité physique adaptée
vieillir est certes naturel mais bien
vieillir cela s'apprend et vous a
présenté celui des rencontres
vous aimez les débats de société mais
aussi les joutes politiques
rejoignez nous dans ça vous regarde tous
les soirs le magazine de la rédaction
dell cp du débat des décryptages mais
aussi des chroniques le tout dans la
bonne humeur
ça vous regarde 19h30 20h30 parce que
les lois qui sont votées ici vous
regarde ça vous regarde présentée par
myriam encaoua demain à 19h30
[Musique]
je
vous venez oui merci tous les
propriétaires qui nous autorise à passer
sur leurs propriétés d'avoir des goûts
pour des caméras ce principalement dans
le fait de pouvoir filmer tous les
impairs qu'ils font aux gens pas d'âme
ces gens c'est incroyable est ce que
aujourd'hui nous pouvons tolérer au 21e
siècle en france on puisse mettre à mort
des animaux de cette manière là aussi
cruel si on parle de quelque chose qui
doit disparaître parce que ces 2010
nobiliaire en l'occurrence j'appelle ça
du racisme social on arrive ça va
arriver un jour se terminer mal
[Musique]
la chasse à courre appelée aussi la
vénerie une tradition plusieurs fois
centenaire 400 équipages dans 69
départements de france un monde à part
mis sous les feux des projecteurs en
octobre 2017
lorsqu'un serre a été abattu dans un
jardin de l'oise à lacroix-saint-ouen
qui pratiquent la chasse à courre
pourquoi le département de l'oise est il
le théâtre d'affrontements avec les
militants anti chasse la vénerie est
devenue une question public et un débat
politique
[Musique]
bonjour savoir comment vas-tu et ça va
être un bien oui
bonjour au coeur de la creuse au petit
matin un rendez vous de chasseurs où
l'on enfile des redingotes d'un autre
siècle prochain approché laurent le guay
a troqué ses habits de commerçants pour
la tenue de maître d'équipage
c'est bon je vais presque tous mordre je
veux remercier tous les propriétaires
qui nous autorise à passer sur leur
propriété
[Musique]
non
faut pas laisser la tradition se perdent
et steam play dans tout ça c'est
justement ce côté organisation ce côté
un petit peu mythique qui a dans tout ça
qui fait rêver et le rêve il est à la
portée de tous en fête la proie de cet
équipage c'est le chevreuil laurent le
guay a sorti une trentaine de chiens
c'est eux qui vont traquer l'animal
l'idée par les chasseurs ils n'ont le
droit de tuer qu'un seul chevreuil
c'est parti pour six heures de course
une traque à cheval ou à pied dans la
chasse à courre les rôles sont
strictement définies cavaliers
rabatteurs ou pick-up armés d'une trompe
et d'un fouet tous doivent avoir le
permis de chasse un peu derrière il y a
les suiveurs que viennent pour le
spectacle ils n'ont pas besoin de permis
de chasse ils sont 1 600 milles dans
toute la france à faire de cette
observation un loisir régulier olivier
outre aucun membre de l'équipage a
choisi aujourd'hui d'être suiveurs
chache loin là-bas dans le bois pour
rester en contact sur les 1800 hectares
de terres pas de téléphone portable le
moyen de communication est le même
depuis des siècles la trompe de chasse
c'est à dire qu'il ya des codes des
fanfares codé qui correspondent aux
différentes circonstances il y en a qui
servent à encourager les chiens y en a
qui servent à les rappeler il ya des
fanfares qui servent à communiquer entre
nous comme ça appelle appelle le fanfare
est d'émettre réponse à l'appel fanfare
inf
on s'appuie uniquement sur les
instruments les plus sains finalement le
seul instrument technologique con et ça
trompe de chasse corps qu'on s'autorise
voilà la chasse traverse uniquement des
terrains privés
la règle est stricte sans autorisation
préalable
impossible de parcourir ses terres tous
ces terrains appartiennent à des privés
simplement c'est des gens qui n'ont pas
voulu se mettre en chasse privée mais
qui n'ont pas voulu interdire droit de
chasse puisqu'il considère que de
retirer assez populaire donc ils
laissent leurs terres à disposition des
chasseurs
on a l'autorisation de passer à peu près
partout sauf les endroits où s'écrit à
jouer alors qu'il faut qu'ils y étaient
mais bon ça tient du passé depuis ce
sens n'a pas utilité de rentrer dans un
parquet complètement fermée bûcheron
peut pas déjà six heures de chasse est
toujours pas de chevreuils mais je
rappelle il ya un ou deux chiens qui
sont sans doute en arrière de la meute
qui sont pas sur la bonne voie peut-être
un peu égaré donc on laisse pas traîner
les chiens derrière le chevreuil recul
qui passe au milieu des chiens vous
commencez à avoir l'animal qui fait des
russes de plus en plus complexes et qui
s'arrêtent qui se tape qui se couche à
côté des chiens qui les laisse passer
qui reprend la voie des chiens pour
mélanger son odeur à celle des chiens là
ça devient vraiment très difficile et la
bête a été cette fois ci plus habile que
la meute
hu jia est qu'on n'a pas été très bon et
là on tombe dedans
une bande de quatre chevreuils et et
puis le chien n'en veulent pas et on
décide d'arrêter simplement simplement
dans le journée compliquée j'en ai très
compliqué dans la chasse au chevreuil
c'est le chien qui tue l'animal sur
trente sorties cette année l'équipage en
a tué sept encore trop diront certains
mais pas pour l'équipage
bien sûr on pourrait éventuellement dire
qu'il ya un acte de fautes et quant à la
prise mais c'est un tout simplement
l'instant une prédation entre deux
espèces une espèce sauvage qui est la
proie est une espèce de moustique qui
sont nos chiens qui font leur métier de
chien et l'animal n'a pas conscience
il se projette pas dans l'avenir s'il
n'a pas la peur de la mort libération
d'hassan soleil mais n'a pas la peur de
la mort un acte naturel de prédateur
qu'il est pourtant interdit de filmer
c'est une consigne nationale donnée par
la société de vénerie on sait bien qu'à
partir du moment où une caméra de
télévision
filmé cette scène sur un reportage qui
avoue je vais apprendre les formats a dû
rentrer 15 secondes et deux minutes
c'est ça qu'on va voir et rien d'autre
voilà pour les raisons pour lesquelles
on est très réticent ça parce que la
seule image que l'on veut montrer d'eux
nous selim al lann images par nom d'un
animal qui va mourir ou qui est mort
pourtant depuis quelques mois
des images de mise à mort circule sur
internet sous titres à l'appui
[Applaudissements]
ces images sont tournées par des
associations dont havas une association
de l'oise jean padam ces gens c'est
incroyable justin en fait partie là il
ya le petit cerf qui est dans la rivière
qui par épuisement s'est réfugié dans
l'eau pour pour avoir une chance
l'équipage de sortie la barque de façon
de pouvoir l'attraper et et le tuer
[Musique]
c'est simplement d'avoir un maximum de
deux pas de preuves d'éléments de façon
à pouvoir bousculer un petit peu
l'opinion publique et que tout voilà
toujours se rendre compte de ce qu'est
la chasse à courre au jour d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
tiens c'était un peu juste pour fournir
ces images justine et les militants
d'havas suivent presque toutes les
chasses à courre des forêts de l'oise
plusieurs fois par semaine nous en fait
on est ici et on aura rendez vous ici au
carrefour des bornes d'âge
[Musique]
ce matin les militants anti chasse vont
suivre l'équipage d'alain drache de la
famille rothschild il loue cette forêt à
l'état 50 mille euros par an pour
chasser le cerf
ici les redingotes sont impeccables et
les rôles répartis depuis des siècles
entre cavaliers et marcheurs
[Musique]
ça n'aurait plus à pécho ce parce que
l'animal il est il fini ce n'est pas
pour les chars s'est pas prononcé bien
diversifiés enfin tu que tu peux lire
qui disent ils réservent les cuissots
pour les meilleurs ou non de ça c'est
pour la paix ces dissimulations de
l'afad comme ses partenaires il est
stressé la viande est immangeable nous
mêler bien sûr que son distributeur
entretenir tous les larbins
bonjour la sûreté de la il est 10h30
presque 11 heures on va arriver alors
rendez vous où ils se réunissent le
matin pour décider de quel animal ils
vont chasser enfin sur quelles traces
ils vont partir en fait donc voilà c'est
le début de la journée pour nous on se
prépare à courir à marcher longtemps
voilà en général c'est une ya 18 ans
alors c'est tous des méchants
non ça c'est le cousin
de là
pour vous
[Musique]
arrivé au point de rendez vous des
chasseurs
une drôle de cohabitation s'installe
deux mondes qui s'affrontent les
militants vont suivre toute la journée
le parcours des chasseurs ans orientaux
aux bruits de la meute et des trompes de
chasse
[Musique]
on rentre ou pas mais là on rentre pas
on arrive l'objectif est d'arriver à
temps pour empêcher la mise à mort du
cerf mais tous les coups ne sont pas
permis
il existe un délit d' obstruction à la
chasse on n'a pas le droit de faire
grand chose
bon hormis se balader en forêt et on n'a
pas le droit de voile admettez des
croquettes à sion de la nourriture de de
toucher les animaux de les emmener des
faire tomber des chevaux de les frapper
des insultes et il est interdit par
exemple d'arrêter la meute ou de
perturber l'odorat des chiens c'est
interdit de la citronnelle de la lavande
oui ça l'esprit de temps en temps mais
enfin moi en tout cas je n'en reviens
pas donc ce qu'on a le droit c'est
simplement quand le cerf il est aux
abois il quand il est encerclé des
chiens on a le droit
c'est le seul moment où ce n'est pas une
acte de chasse d'aller protéger le
cercle daguet pour pour essayer de le
sauver ou de le faire graciée
[Musique]
cette fois encore la meute n'attrapera
aucun animal sans doute grâce à la
présence de la caméra
il n'y aura aucun incident pendant ces
huit heures de traque
mais l'hostilité palpable à ma
connaissance les forêts c'est le domaine
privé de l'état
louez en l'occurrence par nous pour y
chasser à coup oui c'est pesant de voir
des gens qui sont dans l'illégalité
illégalité qu'il ne qu'il ne rejette pas
puisque sur leurs propres fins page
facebook
il montre un film où ils sont en train
d'arrêter mes chiens ce qui est une
obstruction à la chasse et qui sont donc
parfaitement dans l'illégalité
alors effectivement l'ambiance est
tendue
il est exclu d'avoir avec ces personnes
là une discussion sur la vénerie ne
savent pas ce que c'est loin des caméras
de télévision
rappelons public il arrive de plus en
plus souvent que la cohabitation entre
chasseurs et militant dégénère comme ici
toujours dans la forêt de compiègne avec
un autre équipage
je trouve les équipages locaux
remarquablement calme remarquablement
câble quand une fois par semaine ou deux
fois par semaine pour vos loisirs
il avait une bande de zozos pour moi
c'est ça c'est pas autre chose qui
viennent vous empoisonner la vie et vous
empêcher de pratiquer votre activité vos
loisirs appelez ça comme vous voulez ne
pas répondre
par un coup de poing ou par des
mouvements excusez-moi faux voilà ça va
ries un jour se terminer mal parce que
les gens sont à bout à bout et je suis
étonné qu'il ait pas eu de record de
véritablement de coups de poing le
département de l'oise cristallise toutes
les tensions
surtout lorsque la mode s'invite en
centre-ville à pont sainte maxence situé
tout près de la forêt d'halatte insert
surgi dans la rue principale de cette
ville de 13 mille habitants les chiens
et les piqueurs sont d'un autre équipage
c'est la chasse est bientôt quand même
en pleine ville les images une fois de
plus sont fournies par à 20 en plus il
est blessé pour les habitants étaient
très très énervés ils ont d'ailleurs
certains ont pu filmer toute la meute de
chiens plus le sert qui avait saigné en
fait qu'elle ait perdu ses bois le
suiveur nous a dit mais enfin on ne va
pas ne va pas le tuer et j'ai répondu
non
cette fois ci donc là il a commencé à un
peu à faire bon air un peu supérieure et
jeudi mais c'est pas normal à notre
époque d'avoir de telles traditions et
c'est à ce moment là qu'il a dit et
monfils a renchéri et c'est à ce moment
là qu'il a dit à mon fils m'a dit donc
vous ce que vous laissez les kebabs bien
là et arrêter le train est douce
des chameaux c'est à ce moment là que le
maire a senti que ça allait mal tourner
et l'ail les suiveurs sont partis le
cers sera finalement anesthésiés pour
être soigné et remis en liberté
le maire a décidé de porter plainte
les communes peuvent prendre un arrêté
interdisant la chasse à courre dans un
périmètre donné autour des habitations à
pont sainte maxence
c'est 200 m les chasseurs risquent au
moins une contravention de 1500 euros
pour ne pas avoir arrêté la meute avec
la connaissance qu'ils ont de la forêt
avec la connaissance qu'ils ont la
pratique de la chasse à courre
quand même ils doivent bien se douter
que ça peut finir très très mal et qui
doit faire valoir avant tout le principe
de précaution quand vous avez un cerf
qui déboule avec 25 ou 50 chiens
derrière lui et qui prend la direction
d'une ville
à mon avis vous devez vous douter qu'à
un moment donné il faut arrêter la
chasse à courre et qu'il faut dire stop
[Musique]
à l'assemblée un groupe d'une vingtaine
de députés a signé une proposition de
loi visant à abolir la chasse à courre
[Musique]
en dépit de vives eaux qui était privé
en dépit de les couvrir et public un
texte à l'initiative de la france
insoumise une interdiction avec
sanctions à la clé 10
c'est un an d'emprisonnement ses 15000
euros d'amendé
c'est la volonté d'être lettres
dissuasif et de s'assurer que la loi
sera respectée
aujourd'hui il ya 84 % des français qui
considèrent qu' il faut la supprimer
parce que c'est une pratique d'un autre
temps et il faut passer à autre chose
fonctionner différemment
c'est typiquement la le mode de chasse
de la monarchie des rois et aujourd'hui
ce sont encore les plus riches qui qui
pratiquent cette chasse parce que c'est
la chasse qui coûte le plus cher c'est
celle qui rassemble le moins de
deux participants au niveau haut niveau
au niveau français ces quinze mille
participants sur plus de 1,3 million de
chasseurs
donc c'est vraiment une pratique très
minoritaire très élitiste les
signataires viennent de tous les groupes
politiques sauf la nouvelle gauche mais
tous les regards se tournent vers le
groupe majoritaire il ya des députés de
la république en marche qui ont signé
cette proposition de loi
c'est eux qui ont le plus de marge de
manoeuvre pour l'inscription sur à
l'ordre du jour donc maintenant la balle
est dans leur camp
au moins pour pour cette année vu que
nos nichons respectifs sont déjà passées
à l'elysée quelques jours plus tard une
rencontre n'est sûrement pas passé
inaperçu auprès des députés signataires
emmanuel macron recevait les
représentants des chasseurs
à les entendre à la sortie l'abolition
de la chasse à courre n'est pas une
priorité présidentielle
il a donné sa position déjà depuis
longtemps sur la question des chasses
traditionnelles et 40 mode de chasse en
france la chasse à courre
ce n'est pas un sujet pour lui
effectivement issu china globalité de ce
qui se passe au niveau de la ruralité en
matière de chasse ou des autres
utilisateurs de la nature la chasse à
courre a fait en cours en fait partie et
pour lui a aucune ambiguïté là dessus la
colline parlementaire prenne nos
responsabilités et que c'est le présent
république de super qu'il ya des contre
pouvoirs qui évite aussi pour le niveau
du parlement président la république
c'est être à l'écouté de la population
donc il faut 100
pas avoir peur des gros des puissants et
se dire que finalement nous sommes
peut-être plus nombreux et à force de
persévérance d'explication eh ben on va
sûrement avoir raison de la chasse à
courre
je crois pas leurs proches ou prétendent
être présent depuis son coup d'ego entre
le bio ménopausées
moi je me classe et ça sinon je voulais
dire que même si c'est parce que la mini
se sera proposé une autre fois et encore
une autre fois jusqu'à ce que grâce au
mandat est écrit dans les volets les
parlements des motivations d'ordre avec
mention depuis 2005
six autres propositions de loi visant à
interdire la chasse à courre n'ont
jamais abouti
au sénat en octobre dernier un texte
similaire n'a même pas pu être inscrit à
l'ordre du jour plusieurs pays européens
ont aboli la chasse à courre
l'angleterre la belgique et l'allemagne
nous sommes en basse saxe à 100 km de
hambourg une terre traditionnelles de
chasse
à première vue cela ressemble à une
chasse à courre les cavaliers la meute
les costumes la fanfare est juste un peu
poussif
[Musique]
mais ici un cheval est équipé d'un
étrange appareil
je vous explique comment la bouteille
contient du liquide
ce liquide c'est de l'estomac de vaches
on prend un estomac de vache qu'on fait
tremper dans de l'eau et après une
semaine
home et sept autres dans la bouteille
les chiens vont suivre cette odeur on
utilise de l'estomac de vaches parce que
si on utilisait une odeur de renard par
exemple les chiens par tiraient dans
toutes les directions san la descente à
openoffice
[Musique]
on appelle ça le dragon la chasse à la
traîne
le cavalier par avant les autres en
répandant du liquide
suivi deux minutes plus tard de la meute
entraînée par l'odeur
suivi une minute plus tard des cavaliers
[Musique]
le voleur nous ne chassons pas vraiment
nous chassons une odeur donc on peut
planifier où l'on va en france vous ne
sautez pas vous courrez vous courez mais
derrière un animal ici vous pouvez faire
plus de sauts beaucoup plus de sauts
aller dans les ruisseaux complexifier la
course voir différents paysages en
allemagne nous faisons cela depuis plus
de 100 ans à l'origine ça a été créé
pour entraîner la cavalerie de l'armée
la chasse à la traîne est beaucoup plus
rapide qu'une chasse à courre deux
heures de ce qui s'apparente plus à un
parcours d'obstacles qu'à une chasse et
au bout il n'y a pas de gibier je pense
que les allemands ne regrette pas la
chasse à courre attends moi par exemple
je n'ai aucune envie d'y participer je
n'en ai pas besoin c'est pas mon truc
si je veux manger un animal à chante
mais quelle tué au fusil on n'a pas
besoin de faire souffrir pendant des
heures fin de la course
les chiens sont récompensés par de
l'estomac de vache
cette odeur qui l'ont traqué pendant
deux heures vili bat muller un des
maîtres d'équipage a parfois la
nostalgie de la chasse à courre et vient
en france pour la pratique ce que nous
faisons ici c'est une pratique un peu
artificielle en fait c'est bien mais
vous en france vous pratiquez la vraie
chasse traditionnelle celle qui nous
inspire mon hypothèse c'est que cette
tradition va disparaître petit à petit
elle sera donc perdu pour toujours en
allemagne
cela fait plus de 80 ans que la chasse à
courre a disparu et elle ne reviendra
jamais les chiens ne sont plus entraînés
pour le faire les gens ne comprennent
plus la pratique
[Rires]
[Musique]
à
droite suite présenté par jean-pierre
gratien dans un instant c'est le temps
fort de l'actualité du parlement le
gouvernement face aux questions des
députés
présenté par brigitte boucher à 14h
questions d'actualité interview duplex
reportage pour un panorama complet avant
d'entrer dans l'hémicycle
la séance est ouverte à 15 heures les
questions au gouvernement en direct et
en intégralité et à 16h le débrief
prolongement de la séance en compagnie
de deux députés
votre grande session d'actualité
parlementaires à l'occasion des
questions au gouvernement présenté par
brigitte boucher c'est demain à partir
de 14h inédit sur lcp
quand on est bénévole au soleil
on est hyper bien accueilli
on est estivale et à côté il ya tout la
cei nous a tant besoin de chaussures
prestation connais pas c'est beaucoup
d'émotions sortis des listes parce que
la colle au derrière parce que c'est une
grande famille pour moi génération
solidays un documentaire inédit à
retrouver dans trois de suite jeudi à
20h30
il ne reste que 1600 pandas aps
mais ils font tout et n'importe quoi
pour sa sortie
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pas raisonnable les amis
on est menacée d'extinction et nous on
est là un vache i comme des gros plouc
bain pour toi je parle pour tout le
monde louis-georges est pour toi aussi
on est menacé et personne ne se bouge le
cul on était menacée je te signale qu'on
est sorti de la zone rouge
on est remonté de 1600 pandas à 2500
d'où tu sors ces chiffes pierre eustache
raconter c'est les chiffres officiels à
toi tu as confiance dans les chiffres
officiels
pourquoi ils mentir est réfléchie gros
balourd lysandore notre vigilance c'est
ça leur stratégie il nous dit c'est bon
vous pouvez dormir tranquille vous
n'êtes plus menacés résultat tout le
monde se démobilisent nous en premier
tokyo n'est et on s'éteint dans
l'indifférence générale
ils ont pas inventées les chiffres quand
même c'te bonne paire qu'est ce qui les
en empêche
tu as un expert dans son petit bureau il
remplit des cases monde de panda bail
mais ce qu'il veut il se dit tiens je
vais mettre 2500 comme ça on va nous
lâcher la grappe avec les pandas c'est
d'un cynisme il ajouté pour les
manipuler par le pouvoir en place
oui mais si tu vas par la 1600 c'était
peut-être un chiffres bidons aussi si ça
se trouve on était cinquante mille et on
s'est fait des poils blancs pour rien tu
rêves mary mary
la vérité c'est qu'on est menacé alors
ça fait des jaloux les gars troupe les
chiffres pour dire qu'on n'est plus
menacée mais moi on me la fait pas
concrètement qu'est ce que tu proposes
je propose qu'on prenne notre destin en
main on ne fait confiance qu'à nous
mêmes
jeudi concrètement débat concrètement on
refait les comptes
ok c'est parti au départ on était neuf
on se rend compte 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
on est en augmentation personnes a voté
deux fois moi je me souviens même pas si
j'ai voté
bon bah parfait
population en augmentation de 11% tout
danger est écarté reprise de la sieste
[Musique]
est ce que là la forme ne dessert pas le
fond c'est comme si on mettait toutes à
égalité c'est pas facile pour un
gouvernement de changer complètement la
règle du jeu
tu sais déjà ce soir là c'est comme le
ministre de l'intérieur est ce que vous
entendez quand même que l'instant
politique est grave
ce qui importe france a c'est que leur
sécurité soit assurée que vous savez
vous peut-être c'est toujours deux poids
deux mesures n'ayons pas peur des mots
présentée par valérie brochard vendredi
à 20h30
[Musique]